because i think she's also asking two
separate things you know
um you're asking here's here's one thing
by the way when you forgive somebody
you're not
actually giving them anything it's
actually more for you
yeah when you forgive somebody and you
choose to empathize with somebody's
situation
it gives you understanding and it allows
you to let go
that's not the sensation that they get
yeah it's not the same like we're
we're putting our own experience and
thinking that women are
are experiencing the same [ __ ] right so
yeah they're thinking well we like body
parts so maybe we can send the body part
and turn them on
and i think it's the same thing that's
happening here where he feels
like he can't please his woman because
he's not big enough but then what i
in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain
podcast how is everybody doing
salutations and blessings and it's going
to be a fun day because we got
joe jitsukawa howdy do
everybody it's been like five months i'm
happy to be
back on a genius brain show
only one person is allowed to give
people life advice on this at his
[ __ ] joe
and there's been so many like stockpiles
of like yo i need advice i need advice
but there's only one [ __ ] that
can give it to you we just combined
forces man
so first one up we have this is somebody
who's anonymous so when you guys write
the stuff to the genius brain podcast
email or you write it in the patreon
this is from a patreon member they get
first dibs always and here we go
let's talk about some genius suggestions
baby uh
today is a hey guys big fan of the
podcast
love listening to your episodes as i go
about my daily life
the i can't get girls because i'm asian
episode really resonated with me as i
was that person before
oh good the first step is to realizing
your addictions uh i grew up the only
asian in a white countryside town oh
that's hard
and was bullied and i hated myself for
being asian oh man
poor dude everybody has those personal
stories like the way that you think
it's never just it never just happens
out of nowhere there's always
something for the reason why you either
behave a certain way or you have a
certain mindset
and clearly that this was it poor dude
man yeah
however after moving away to america as
a teen i was surrounded by asians that
were comfortable with their race and i
shed that part of myself away by working
on different parts of my life
having relationships and becoming more
confident so i agree a lot with your
idea that asian men need to better
themselves to change pers
uh the the perception of them yeah kind
of kind of like that but more
more than the sense of just don't make
uh excuses for it
and there's probably a lot of other
reasons other other than the fact that
you're asian that you're not getting
yeah work on yourself not you know think
about yourself as a
title or a label yeah good for you guy
um however
i'm curious what country he you left to
he says he left to america he left out
of america
yeah i wonder too damn well are you
chinese korean indian yeah
however there's something that is still
eating at me and i'd like to remain
anonymous
if possible no problem jason i'm kidding
i'm [ __ ] around that's not his name
he didn't put his name on you uh i had a
negative sexual experience with a girl a
korean girl
uh after we hooked up she messaged some
mutual friends and made fun of me for
having a small dick
i did not expect that i mean well
she's asian herself right yeah so like
it's not like a white girl is going
around and saying you got a little dick
yeah so uh first of all i don't mean to
laugh at you it's just i didn't think
that that was the advice that you're
gonna ask for
i know it is it is kind of shocking yeah
it threw me off because he's all like
i have this hard like thing actually she
[ __ ] made fun of my dick
like i don't know yeah yeah kind of well
whatever that's [ __ ] up yeah yeah what
a [ __ ] let's start with that
um maybe you can message all her friends
and say she had a stinky ass [ __ ]
and you had to go get tested because you
thought that you were going to get some
kind of disease from her
so this is not the first time as another
girl oh my goodness
another girl also asian told me my dick
was small before as well
you have very interesting women in your
life
uh i've tried i've tried to push this
out of my mind as people tell me it's
not the size that matters in bed
but unlike my character job or personal
life it is not something that i can work
on
and change i know there will always be
women with their own personal
preferences but i can't seem to shake
this feeling of inadequacy i think it
sucks that
okay i don't even know how you even get
into this conversation or are women just
saying
oh that's a small dick like what what's
happening here yeah there's like two
things that i kind of want to watch
so confused i wish you would have sent
me a picture of your dick so i could go
and see this as well just because at
this point it's all imagination baby
and there are honestly like
women come in different shapes and sizes
right
yeah and okay unless you have a micro
penis
i think it's going to be completely
difficult or different like there's
petite girls out there that yeah yeah
i mean they can handle big dicks and
i've seen many
um very good films
you call it a film
some award-winning films i've seen some
really good
award-winning spectacular artistic films
where
sometimes you see the actress and you go
wow
how is this uh
you know school girl petite school girl
gonna [ __ ]
be able to fit this baby arm yeah
i guess she makes it work and i'm just
like wow
but at the same time like i mean just
from my own experience
girls do feel different too like there's
somewhere they're just like
super loose and i feel like i'm just
thrusting air and there's some that are
like
super duper tight that it kind of hurts
and i don't enjoy having sex with them
and then like
there's a thrusting air that
[ __ ] is a [ __ ]
cave of wonders how many people have
blasted their penis inside that thing i
don't even know if it's that it just
might be
just a loose vagina just a different
size practice your kegels
yeah i don't know we're just different
sizes we're not meant to fit i guess
but like i'm pretty sure the that girl
probably thinks i have a small ass dick
and then the other girl who
like i was like damn it just so tight
that it hurt me and it's not enjoyable
she probably thinks like oh you're
[ __ ]
stallion right so it could be that
maybe it just depends on the women that
you're with
yeah so he's asking i was he so he says
um
i know there will always be women with
their own personal preferences but i
can't seem to shake this feeling of
inadequacy
which is affecting my confidence when
approaching women i've seen a therapist
about this but it has not helped so far
i was wondering if you had any advice on
getting out of this mindset
and run yeah learn how to eat some [ __ ]
really good like
honestly like there's there's other ways
okay so i think a lot of guys too
think that having okay the
the intercourse right like having a so
we think
we get pleasure through um
intercourse like putting it in right
yeah so like because
the the best feeling is like around her
head or whatever
and then well women their head is their
their [ __ ]
it's not even in the [ __ ] it's like on
the top yeah so like
filling her up and doing that
i've heard that it's so different
depending on
who you're talking to like some girls
like
you know they're like yeah i don't
really you know care about being filled
up
like that and then big dicks actually
suck or like whatever
and then if you think about most dildos
or just most like
toys they're smaller you know they're
not as big as you think
it's like pornos make you think having a
big-ass dick and you're filling her up
and you're putting her through pain is
like the [ __ ] but
i don't think that basically i don't
think that
guy's our criteria
for our size and all that is as
important as we think it is
yeah just from all the evidence and just
from the talking to women and like from
that like
obviously i think a woman can explain
this better than i can because
i'm not a girl and i don't know the
sensations but
the evidence points to that
it doesn't seem to matter that much and
how many women actually say
it's not about the size like science
don't [ __ ] matter i think for him the
harsh part is is that he heard from
two people that he was sexually active
with yeah he said that his his dick was
small
but they not like it though like because
that's there's one thing to saying small
but then it's like
different from being unpleasurable like
if you have a micro penis and it doesn't
fill me up and it's unpleasurable like
because you can be big and unpleasurable
i wish you would have gave us like a
size metric like if you said that
okay i have a four inch penis right
that's not a micro penis
it's it's it's not a microphone it's not
but at the same time
i think like i'm saying is like guys
don't know
how okay like the way that it's kind of
like this like guys send dick pics to
girls right because they think that
they're all gonna [ __ ] like this [ __ ]
but they're like
that's not the sensation that they get
yeah it's not the same like we're
we're putting our own experience and
thinking that women
are are experiencing the same [ __ ] right
so they're thinking well we like body
parts so maybe we can send the body part
and turn them on
and i think it's the same thing that's
happening here where he feels
like he can't please his woman because
he's not
big enough but then what i realized is
that
the reason why a lot of women say like
it doesn't matter the size is because
there's so many
other things that you can do to make her
[ __ ] calm because now i'm wondering
too like in his case
um first of all my friend i've never had
this problem
but uh like i'm [ __ ] around no but
seriously i never have but in in your
case too
maybe you're just not good at [ __ ]
yeah it's like it might it might be that
it could you know
because you know we're not i don't want
to be as first of all uh
when it comes to that's another
insecurity that he could get now too
he's like not only is his dick small he
can't [ __ ] either
my bad bro but i'm trying to make you
feel better
um number one i haven't i'm not i
haven't been as sexually active as other
men right i think when it comes to
sexual partners i probably had about
us maybe like six or seven seven or
eight something like that right
not very much for for someone who's been
around for 30 years right
compared to my friends they've had i
know some guys that are
in their hundreds yeah hundreds 30s 40s
right yeah i've never been that sexually
active i was more of a
get to know somebody and kind of develop
like a romantic relationship
and that kind of brings me that way
right um one of the things that i did
and i and i mentioned this
before back in the day in a vlog was
that uh
i used to have this perception that i
was really that i thought i was decent
at sex only because
if i thought if i felt good that the
other person would feel good as well
right
not the [ __ ] case had no [ __ ] idea
there was one girl that i dated
um she was more sexually experienced
than i was and she was older
when we had sex i remember i asked her i
was like how was it and she goes
meh and she went met and that [ __ ]
[ __ ] hurt my feelings like what the
[ __ ] do you mean
and then she kind of told me like why i
wasn't very good at what i thought i was
good at right
it had nothing to do with a size factor
had nothing to do with anything else
right
had everything to do with the fact in my
case anyways that i thought if it felt
good for me it felt good for her yeah
right
but there was just a whole other there
was a
the foreplay aspect that i wasn't
thinking about there was an emotional
aspect i wasn't thinking about
a whole other stuff obviously some
people are just are just down to [ __ ]
all the time if that's the type of woman
that you're looking for
i can't really speak for that because i
haven't been with women like that before
so um but in that case and it seems like
you're in a serious relationship
um conversation is something that you
should have if something if
if having sex is not something that you
consider your forte which isn't
something of mine as well
but conversation is key like i've in my
serious relationships i've always asked
what they like
how they like it and if they dislike
something yeah and is this
is the small meme bad yeah i think
that's the thing too
cause like i don't know man i know
to me like i have yet to meet a woman
where she's like
i want a such a big [ __ ] dick that it
rips my [ __ ] apart
and i can't walk for days like guys are
always talking like that it's like i
[ __ ] her so good she could have walked
for days you know and then like
i guess rarely i've i actually don't
even know one
yeah where i heard what a girl is like
yeah i want a dick that's
massive and it [ __ ] feels so big and
it hurts me
like i'll put it in perspective like
this right so
uh i wasn't a part of this conversation
but the
the this was from a group of homegirls
right and they were talking about dick
size right
and this there's a couple of things that
you could take away from this like
number one how either guys lie about
dick size or number two
girls don't know the actual size of
[ __ ] dicks that go inside them
right so and that could also be because
guys lie about dick size that they think
that this is what it actually
is so in these uh group of friends that
i know and this conversation came to me
we were all just chopping up just joking
around
and uh one of our friends she goes
i she goes she goes i like big dicks
right and they're like oh okay like you
like big dicks like okay what would you
mean big dick right
and so uh one of the girls they were
[ __ ] around and then she showed them
a picture of a of a dick
right she had a dick on her phone yeah
and she goes is this too big or is this
too small right she goes that's [ __ ]
she looks pretty big
and they're like oh that's big to you i
mean how big is that that's like eight
inches
right yeah i didn't see the dick but the
girls were cracking the [ __ ] up
because it wasn't an eight inch dick it
was like an average like fiverr or
something like that right she goes you
think this is an eight inch stick she
goes that's like eight inches right it's
like no it's not it's not [ __ ] eight
inches so
you know even like this perception of
size unless the girl's whipping out a
[ __ ] ruler yeah
you know like was she gonna know how
does she really know and this girl
wasn't also a very sexually active girl
too
oh but in her mind was she considered a
huge penis was actually wasn't that
[ __ ]
big right which is just pretty average
which is which was an average
dick it was whatever five inches
according to the to the girl that was
talking about it right
and it that that in and of itself just
kind of shows how arbitrary size is
sometimes
if if i were to say it from that
perspective because this girl was
talking about she likes big [ __ ] or
whatever
and what she saw that what she said was
a big penis was an average sized penis
and a big [ __ ] to me is like three soda
cans stuck that
up you know and you know porn also kind
of [ __ ] up a lot of people's perception
of what a huge penis should be
this podcast is brought to you by better
help is there something interfering with
your happiness or is preventing you from
achieving your goals
maybe you realize that your mental
health needs a boost or is just
something you haven't really focused on
in your life
i personally have done online counseling
and therapy and it's been great mental
health has been a huge
focus in my life especially the past
year and it's something that i believe
that people should tend to
on a consistent basis better help is
great because they can match you with
your own professional license
therapist you can schedule your sessions
via phone communicate and message online
video calls
and you can even change your counselors
if needed if you want to give this a try
of course for my genius brain listeners
i got the hookup for you to get 10 off
your
first month of betterhelp just type in
betterhelp.com
genius to get that offer today once
again
that's b e t t e r h
e l p dot com slash genius to get
10 off your first month of better help
to a better you
right because you're seeing these girls
like yeah i want this huge dick and it's
literally half their [ __ ] face it's
like the biggest thing i've ever seen in
my [ __ ] life
you know and i've seen a lot of naked
men at the spa and i'm just like
that's not the average dude like when
you're in the korean spot you might see
one i call them uh sunday hyungs
the [ __ ] black sausage the big ass
you might see one or two but a lot of
them are not like that yeah
you know so it's it's it's very odd how
we do this comparison game
i think it sucks for you in the case
that you had two women who are very
insensitive by the way
dude that sucks yeah or he could have
been like so how is it is my dick normal
is it what what are you oh maybe he
asked and then she's like
yeah it's kind of small yeah you know
and and then like the
the fact that just hearing that it's
small and then like he doesn't
know any like he has to draw his own
conclusions that means he didn't
ask the right questions and if it's
something that you're so
quote unquote insecure about or you feel
like you have a small dick right
like and you're already going into that
thought which is already hard to deal
with in and of itself
you do realize that there's a lot of
other ways for you to fulfill
that sexuality there's guys with no dick
man there's guys that lose their [ __ ]
dick to cancer and then they're like
still finding ways to get with hundreds
of women like there's a story of this
guy he's like a [ __ ] rico
suave and he knows how to like eat [ __ ]
like a master
and he just keeps dating so many women
i think that the feeling of inadequate
he just feels like maybe he can't change
this about himself
and that you know he's no longer going
to be able to please women but
like i said like he's putting himself
and thinking
from a guy's perspective right and it's
almost like
blanketing and thinking that all women
are like one [ __ ] way
but the cool thing about human beings is
like
a lot of people just want different
things yeah like
not everybody you know some some
people i know like they don't even want
to have intercourse they just want to
have oral sex all day
like so it really depends like you can't
outright think that you're not going to
be able to please someone because
i don't know man it just doesn't work
that way also too it really depends
because if you're if you're
trying to just casually hook up with
somebody and they're saying like oh
like his dick is small [ __ ] you
you knew what you was walking into
you're just casually hooking up with
somebody yeah you know it is what it is
if you got a small
dick and dems is facts boy dems is facts
that's all that it is
it's like imagine this well what if you
had a normal dick or a big dick but then
it didn't work
like because there are people out there
that that had that and then they're just
like
they'll be like well i would gladly take
a small dick that works
yeah right like or what if you had i
mean there's just so many different
things like and to worry about like yeah
and if you're thinking about just like
the hookup situation too
whatever happens in a hookup situation
it happens and you shouldn't really take
any
any weight with it because it's
something that's an on and off thing
right and if i'm like i said i don't
know the size of your dick right
but let's just say per se it's like
three inches
yeah that's a pretty small [ __ ] dick
if you have a really tiny dick and
that's what they observed and they've
never been with a penis that small
they might say that i think more of a
problem would be if you were in a in a
committed relationship and this is
something that
has been bothering her for a while yeah
if it's a hook-up situation who cares
whatever you got it you hooked up with
the person you're not looking for a
long-term relationship then why does it
matter
yeah you know an average size i heard
like
there's like a chart of all these
different average sizes
from a condom company so like there's
i don't know like there's places in the
world where like
three inches is normal or whatever and i
think like
just look at the chart i think it was
like
vietnam or thailand or one of the
southeast asian countries but they have
a different
size like level it's different from the
uh from america and i know because like
i um i used a vietnamese condom
for scientific scientific purposes
and i thought something was weird
because it didn't feel the same
yeah and then my friend's like oh yeah
yeah you gotta bring american ones like
it just
it's like i was like i thought it was
just cheaper or some [ __ ] and then
they're like no no it's like
it's just tighter and smaller and i was
like oh [ __ ] i didn't know that
so hey man like like i said like
different strokes for different folks
yeah it just it kind of sucks with this
trauma thing i'm not going to tell you
just to kind of get over it
because i don't know what it's like to
be in that situation neither but at the
same time
for you you know you can't just base
your whole sexual experience off of two
two very particular things
like once again if you if you know that
for a fact let's say you do have a micro
penis
then that is what it is it is right but
if you have like a regular
length girthed penis and somebody tells
you that it's small
i i don't think that's really a you
issue in terms of size it might be more
of an issue of how you used it
uh if you're good at [ __ ] maybe you
never really had a conversation with a
girl where you actually figured out
uh good things or dope [ __ ] to do that's
the funny thing is like
some of these dudes who get advice from
uh other dudes about
how a woman's body works is [ __ ]
ridiculous because you should probably
ask a woman
yeah you know she'll she'll a girl
fascinating dude because
they're it's so different too you you
can talk to a thousand different girls
and it's just so
different like for all it's not like
guys yeah
you find out how to make one guy come
it's like pretty simple pretty much
figured out the rest
yeah but for girls it's like they're all
different it's like having a [ __ ]
1982 corolla
that only only the owner knows how to
make it work you gotta [ __ ] dangle
the key
you gotta [ __ ] slap the top you gotta
do all this other [ __ ] blink the lights
yeah and then maybe the engine will turn
on
yeah a girl is like a nintendo game you
gotta [ __ ]
you gotta blow the [ __ ] cartridge you
gotta [ __ ] spit on the cartridge and
[ __ ] blow on it
you gotta put it under your t-shirt and
blow on that
dude it's it's it's interesting though
in your case man like
it sucks that i guess that was the
conversation kind of sucks that the girl
went and told her friends and it kind of
got to you
i mean you know people be chatting i'm
pretty sure guys do the same thing i
know man that sucks it sucks that you
ought to hear that
um it's a pretty big deal though when we
used to run ask the feels
it was like pretty much conversations
like sexual [ __ ]
and every week we would have we would
have about
at least 20 to 30 questions of
guys saying that is my dick big enough
because i think it's like a big deal
for guys to have like a good sized
penis i remember the first time i saw
one of my friends dicks
this [ __ ] did you he was how do
you see your friend's dick so this is
what happened right
so he would always say that he had a big
dick right
as a joke as an ongoing joke this guy
was a very unique human being by the way
i'm talking about
he's such an odd human being that when
we used to play ball this [ __ ]
used to always hoot while smoking a cig
he always had he always had a cigarette
in his [ __ ] mouth
he's talking about how big his dick is
he would always [ __ ] play ball
with a [ __ ] uh [ __ ] marble in his
[ __ ] mouth just
uh smoking up and shooting he's a very
odd character but he was always talking
about how big his dick was and one time
he got really drunk and he was like you
guys want to see my dick and we're like
no we don't want to see your [ __ ]
dick he goes
well you don't got a [ __ ] choice he
doesn't whip it out right he just
outlines his dick on his basketball
shorts and that [ __ ]
was a [ __ ] tumor that [ __ ]
was huge
i i was shocked he's like maybe 5'4
if he fell over he would be fine he
would just balance on that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] thing was huge i had
a homegirl that hooked up with him yeah
and
she said that it was huge but she didn't
say it in a good way
she said it was like ugh she was well i
mean she was a pretty uh small
little korean girl but that thing was
huge
and but he would talk about it he's like
you want to see it
he would talk about it like it was his
you know crown jewel like it was
there's nothing else going for him smoke
the secrets of play ball
but you know in that case when that girl
was talking about it she was like yeah i
was really uncomfortable or whatever
but even for me when i was younger i
didn't really care i was like i still
wish i had that big old dick though
but you know everybody different strokes
were different folks yeah there might be
a girl out there who's who has a
cavernous [ __ ]
and that he might have to fill have you
seen bobby lee's dick
no i've really for all the times you've
been there
i saw the back of his ball sack oh what
we were
we were doing a live tiger belly show
yeah and this fool was up and about
and of course he decided to strip at his
show and his ball
bobby lee's ball sack hangs so [ __ ]
low i could see it from behind
really that [ __ ] he showed me his dick
oh my god
why he came downstairs and it was a
george and [ __ ] um [ __ ] uh
gilbert and we're just hanging out and
you know how like
in his set well back then uh it was that
closet with the mirror
yeah and then he pulled down his pants
and he's checking if his dick is still
there
and he's like man it's not getting
bigger
or worse oh [ __ ] he said some funny [ __ ]
like that right
and i was like holy [ __ ] and he turns
around and he shows uh
george or i forgot if it was georgia
bryce but he was
standing by the camera and i was like is
this an everyday
thing that's [ __ ] funny dude that
feels hilarious yeah man yeah but i saw
the back of his ball sack also kid
if you're fat and you lose weight the
fat will disappear around your penis
it'll make you look bigger i know for a
fact
i know for a fat it's true damn
on to the next one i hope that helped
you out anonymous
dick talk dick talk uh here's another
one
hi david uh i listen i listen to most of
your podcast and a lot of what is said
on podcast resonates with me and it
actually helps me understand my own
feelings reactions because
sometimes i just don't know how to put
how i feel into words
i'm from the oc okay what's up you were
on the corner
uh so it's super cool to watch someone
who can speak and relate to [ __ ] that i
go through with lies within the vicinity
of me um this is going to be a long
story
my name i don't know if you told me to
be a number i'm just going to fake your
name just in case
my name is priscilla i'm 26 years old
my mom had me at the age of 17. okay
okay
your mom's a little abg and my dad was
22 years old
he is an asian gang member interesting
okay
uh a member that is now serving a life
sentence with without parole from a
crime he committed in 1996
damn he was one of the og's from that
era
from my understanding when my dad found
out my mom was pregnant he left and
moved away
i never found out about my dad's
incarceration until i grew older my mom
picked up
the pieces and she worked at jobs that i
wasn't proud of i witnessed my mom bring
multiple men around me
and i get confused with their names and
so to make it easier for her
she would make me call them all daddy so
i don't have to keep track of who's who
i grew up seeing and feeling uh
physically slash verbal abuse all the
time i see my uncle get stabbed in front
of me
damn girl what the [ __ ] is going on um
and while growing up with a broken
culture uh all this occurred before i
was the age of 10.
[ __ ] dude this is a lot of trauma
my grandma raised me for most of my life
she is deaf so my first language is sign
language and then english that's [ __ ]
dope
people would question why i don't speak
vietnamese if my ethnicity is vietnamese
it would be complex to explain my
situation so sometimes i'd lie and say
i'm another race to avoid these
questions
i used to question why did i learn a
pointless language that i can only use
with my grandma and no one else
it was aggravating that i can't
understand or fluently speak the
language of my own people
and i grew bitter knowing i was going to
be an outcast from the very beginning
my high school peers would spread rumors
about me being a [ __ ] because they
spotted my mom working in a vietnamese
coffee shop
those are fantastic institutions by the
way people would tell me all girls who
work in these vietnamese coffee shops
are [ __ ] and [ __ ]
jesus uh they would not really yeah
vietnamese coffee okay we're gonna talk
about that they would taught me they
would taunt me and say
uh like mother like daughter uh i was in
a dark place all throughout high school
because of these misconceptions
i asked myself why don't i fit in
anywhere why do people always treat me
different everywhere i go
am i disgrace to the vietnamese
community was i born in the world to be
a fuck-up
moving every year took a toll on my
ability to make connections it was hard
for me to
find real friends because i wasn't able
to relate to any of them the ones i
finally found in a
uh find any kind of connection were bad
news and they couldn't understand
support my background traumas the way i
wanted them to
i felt like i stuck out like a sore
thumb everywhere i go i would seek
validation from others often and this
led to poor judgment
and into a lot of bad situations which
is kind of cool that you're very
self-aware though
i'm horrified to have children because i
feel like i would fail as a parent if
they went
if if they went through what i went
through as of today i don't speak to my
mom or dad
my dad tried reaching out to me when i
was 14 years old but at that point i
felt he missed that opportunity to make
a connection with me in the back of my
mind
i feel that he's only talking to me
because he's in there and i'm out here
after all he made his choice and left me
and my mom my mom was bad with
money so she would take money for my
brother and me for uh for her gambling
habits
i feel like they both failed as my
parents i cut them off both of
off completely after high school so i'm
not reminded of my past i can tell
people judge me without fully
understanding my situation
uh people judge me for not having a
father and automatically labeled me a
[ __ ] since that's how they viewed my
mom
if i wasn't made to fit then i wanted to
teach the uh myself that i had to
present a tough exterior so i
can stop being bullied thus i surrounded
myself with gang members
so you can see how this was setting me
up to go down a bad path i wanted to
belong somewhere even if i if it meant
sacrificing my sanity and dignity for
that kind of validation
i witnessed enough stabbings and
shootings to finally understand that
this is not the life i want to live
because one day
i'll end up in a body bag and no one
would look would look after my grandma
or my younger half brother
it took me a long time to pull myself
out of that hole and not get my act
together i wish i got it together sooner
than i did then maybe i wouldn't have
suffered as much my question for you
how can you escape the gang life sooner
if that's all you knew growing up
man this is actually really good because
i know quite a few people who have done
this
uh me myself included there it is
because i
yeah i thought it's gonna be great i
should have got out of this sooner
yeah yeah is it okay to not forgive or
let toxic family members back into your
life
oh that's a good one too am i being too
stubborn to let anyone in due to my
defense mechanism or do i have the right
to feel and enforce the way i feel
thank you for reading this far i know
it's a handful i feel that uh
i felt that you would know how to reply
in a logical way that makes sense to me
i waited so long to finally write it all
out and even if it's on this platform
and gets ignored skipped i feel now
i feel like i know where i finally stand
with my own feelings
and she has a link to where i well i
could read about her dad's case later
this is so interesting right and we've
always talked about this too
um how
when i was younger i would probably have
looked at somebody like this and i would
have had a
already a preconceived notion about who
this person is right
nobody is ever the way that they are
simply because of it we say this
repetitively on this podcast
should have been my homegirl i know but
you know what the thing is she would
have been my [ __ ]
girlfriend i don't know like this was my
world bro like this is
it's so interesting and it's so
interesting that you bring this up
because i think um
it's interesting how young she is but
this
is more of how current it was when it
was when we were younger
your story actually right now though
it's very
for a lot of people might seem very
unique i knew a lot of people like this
and it's funny because like maybe that
it's so weird like that's why kids
bullied her
but then i like so
growing up this was more normal yeah so
you wouldn't feel so
weird like exercised yeah because
there's so many kids that are in the
same shoes like
with parents that are in in in crime or
they're
they're they're doing some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] you know they're
gambaholics or whatever it is like half
of my school was like that
so um all the kids that were goody two
shoes are
judgmental or whatever they were
terrified of what we would
do to them if they made us feel any type
of negativity
it's weird because i specifically
don't know how you feel but i do
understand what it feels like to be
ostracized
what it feels like to be pushed aside
and i do understand what it feels like
not to belong anywhere especially at a
very young age
especially because of certain stuff that
you didn't do
like you are now being judged for the
behavior of your parents
and it makes sense like she went down
the path of
confining in people that went through
trauma
similar to hers because it's true like i
always said this too it's like i get
way closer to people who's been through
physical abuse or who's been through
like lower income situations because
for me um you know like you know it's
it's not
to me i think class brings people closer
than race
yeah like sometimes yeah you have
culture and race but then
for me like we have this multicultural
group of friends but
what ties us together is also kind of
family dysfunction
being from lower income situations and
and and having a lot of relatable
past trauma and so it doesn't matter if
you're white or mexican or asian like
our
group of friends can all relate to that
and so we've we had this talk before
like upper middle class
rich asian kids like we'll have friends
right like
at this age you can make friends with
anyone but
that closeness and that level of like
loyalty that you you learn on the
streets and whatever
they don't have that yeah they don't get
it they don't
know what it's like to survive with each
other right so it's it's
they have something different and
something special that they can relate
to
but for me that belonging and having
someone understand you it's really
it's it's it's really important it's
even tougher
when you leave that situation and you
become more successful and you just
cannot um you feel alone so yeah so yeah
but at her age though i get it because
she's not at that point yet
where once you get to a certain level
and you become successful you realize
how common your story is you're going to
meet a lot of people that
rose out of these situations from
different races and you're gonna
be able to find that love within these
people
but you're in a hard stage right now
because you don't know
if what you're doing is the right thing
so for example you ask the question
of is it right for me to leave people in
the dust
and i think yeah 100 i did the same
thing
and i always tell people in order for
you
to receive people and help them you know
grow
or or love them again you need to be
strong and you need to love yourself
if you don't then you become um
you basically fall into a trap because
you're not strong enough
to withstand whatever negativity they
have for you
and that's the thing right so like a lot
of people
they want to service other people
because they have a good heart or or
whatever it is
but they themselves aren't strong enough
to lift anybody up
so i said build yourself up that's why i
tell everybody like for me too like
i create brown boundaries between me and
my dad i brought them back into my life
you know like
um but i'm at this age and stage where i
understand
what my limits are with each individual
you don't give a thousand percent every
single time
right you gotta do it in stages and so
you have at well well the bottom line is
like you don't have
any obligation to anyone right so
for example yes your mom you know she
did the best that she
could maybe maybe she [ __ ] up who
knows right but she was a teen
mom and and and so through right now
it's hard to see this because cause you
know i think
that when you look at her you're just
like [ __ ] you could have done better why
were you so irresponsible or whatever
but at the end of the day she
tried to feed you maybe she tried to
figure life out but
i i created a rule for myself if my
parent did a little bit better than
their parent
then fine they did a good job sure they
could have done better by looking at
other people's parents you see that
[ __ ] i wish my parents were just as
loving and great as them
but you can't use that criteria because
they had better grandparents and their
great-grandparents did better
that's why their family is a completely
they're on a different wavelength
they're on a different stage right
and then for your own family you just
gotta see it this way
and when you see it this way you go oh
[ __ ] you know what
with the cards that my parents were
given they
did the best that they could because
they just didn't know any better and
when you have that empathy
it and you and you're able to forgive
them
you kind of lift the pain because you
can't hold that pain for you
forever it's going to [ __ ] kill you
like like just coming from a person
who's um you know had a father who left
similar story to you
and um you know i resented my mom
because she was weak she was uh
like she she wasn't like my other
friend's moms who
ended up owning a home and she was
financially stable my mom was
uh always you know passive and getting
stepped on by other people
and i kept looking at her and i was just
like why are you so weak right
but then empathy is is built when you
understand someone's history
so when i realized that my grandma was a
tyrant and she was super controlling of
my mom
my mom never built this independent self
of a of a woman like and i was like how
did this happen because my grandma's so
strong and she's so
independent and she's always taking
charge and i realize that she's so
strong to the point where she didn't let
anybody around her
becomes stronger than her so she was in
turn kind of weak
because she was controlling and then so
when you start to see that
generationally right like the reason why
everyone's acting the way that they do
for example your parents
they didn't just one day decide to be
criminals or
didn't just one day decide this is
something that's happened
years and it's because they had shitty
parents so you know whatever
and sure you had a loving grandparent
but
everyone knows that the way your
grandparent treats you is different from
how your grandparent
treated their your mom right so
you can't see it the same way and so
right now there's a lot of pain in your
heart and the easiest thing for you to
do is blame that's okay
it's a way of coping and it's it's a way
of getting
over it but you shouldn't feel forced to
love them again and you shouldn't feel
forced to to to bring them back into
your life you have
no absolutely no obligation to doing
that because
you are the child and for you
your job is to build yourself up and
[ __ ]
everybody else around you and their
opinions because i think
she's also asking two separate things
you know um you're asking
here's here's one thing by the way when
you forgive somebody
you're not actually giving them anything
it's actually more for you yeah
when you forgive somebody and you choose
to empathize with somebody's situation
it gives you
understanding and it allows you to let
go you're not actually doing it for
them you have to understand some this is
i mean i don't know if people agree or
disagree with this but when i forgive
somebody
i'm not doing it for you yeah i'm doing
it for me and forgiveness doesn't mean
you're completely allowed to come into
my life
exactly forgiveness is just i understand
that you made a mistake and it's i
i'm moving past that yeah like when i
say like i forgive somebody who has done
some [ __ ] up things in my past
that's not in all access all access
passed back into my life
that doesn't mean i ever forget all the
stuff that you've done yeah it doesn't
mean that it's a representation of who
that person is now
it's a representation of where i want to
be and where i'm at now
so if i forgive this person who did some
[ __ ] up things i'm saying like listen
i don't want to hold this [ __ ] against
you because it weighs me down it doesn't
mean that you have to let
i have to let that person back in yeah
forgiveness to me is like
releasing the thought yeah of so you can
live
so you so you don't hold on to the pain
you don't keep thinking about it you go
you know what
i'm moving on so this is a release but i
think a lot of people confuse
forgiveness with i'm going to
let you have my trust again yeah those
are two different things it's very
different because trust is things that
you have to
nurture and build over time you have to
take baby steps into it right just
because you forgive someone doesn't mean
that
now they have this like open arm
come back into my life everything is the
way that it's gonna be you know or
should be or whatever
that's not the same [ __ ] and we'll have
that conversation too where some people
will say
you know i'm pretty sure we've heard
people in our life say this they go i
thought you forgive me i thought we're
cool
no i forgave you doesn't mean we're cool
though yeah that means that
you know now i can be very cordial with
you so
i i don't want you to confuse that like
like joe
said everything is a is a process right
so
if you do want to let your parents back
into your life and you know people do
have this phrase where they say you know
you only get one set of parents
a hundred percent true but it doesn't
really
erase all the stuff that they've done to
you in the past i'm not telling you to
hold on to these things and i'm also not
telling you at the same time
is to just openly just let them back
into your lives you have to understand
where are you at right now
yeah if you're a strong enough
individual where you can go ahead
and talk to your father who is
incarcerated talk to your father who
who made a choice to leave you if you
have
the mental capacity if you have the
wherewithal to withstand that
then please by all means when you are
ready do it yeah
but it's going to take steps it's not
something that you're going to say
okay you know what i'm being a little i
feel like i'm being [ __ ] up to my dad
i'm just going to let him write it no
pump your [ __ ] brakes and then take
those steps
maybe send him a letter right start
there ask him questions get to know him
a little bit and even with your mom too
if you want to make that choice to have
that person in your life it's going to
be completely up to you there is no set
of [ __ ] rules
if your heart is not ready for that
stuff if you're in a stage of life right
now like you said where you're still a
part of a gang
and you're still trying to figure that
part out well well maybe we'll address
that later
right let's get to the forgiveness and
empathy part first
and then we'll we'll we'll pick up on
those parts because as of right now what
it sounds like
is that your life right now is is kind
of on
very shaky stilts right like you're you
don't really have your balance
yeah work on you find stability and
you're doing the best thing is you
realize that you got to cut certain
people away
that's the hard part i hate that that
that's that saying people go oh blood is
thicker than water
[ __ ] that you need to be
like this is why i recommend everybody
to like if you can
move away for college find your own
person
move away from the city that you're in
because we become so dependent on the
opinions of
family and friends yeah like and
the more people are in your ear or the
more you constantly worry about what
people think of you
you don't have the ability to form your
own thoughts
and your own words those are other
people's words
so what i mean by that is like we're
constantly talking to ourselves in our
minds right like it's
constantly running in and and most of it
could be like
worrying about what other people are
thinking or whatever that's why
you know sometimes these hippies go out
and they go i gotta
find myself so i'm gonna frolic in the
[ __ ] indian jungle
you know but they got a good point
because you need to
be in a completely new environment where
you're not doing the same routine yeah
and you're a different person and no one
knows who you are and if you can't
afford it or
or you can be in a just a different
place right and they see you differently
and
and you're treated differently like
you're gonna start thinking different
and i think that's super important to do
for everyone
you have to have your own thoughts you
have to be strong
and you have to be sure of yourself
before you
go into these situations because the
thing that a lot of people don't do is
like
you know a lot of people might watch
their spending but there's emotional
spending
and we only have so much on a daily
basis right
and a lot of people are just
irresponsibly giving away their
like stress man that [ __ ] that shit's
dude
this is like some stuff that we've we've
been going through this year alone yeah
it's dealing with other people's stress
to the point where it starts to diminish
us on our everyday
yeah you know and i didn't realize this
stuff like i didn't get it either
because i'm trying to be the good friend
i'm trying to have an open ear and an
open heart and an open mind
but there's a certain point where there
there there's too much take and not
enough give
you know and it starts to wear us out
mentally and emotionally and it starts
to affect my personal life
so we have to be very mindful of this
stuff as well and there was a question
that you asked at the end too which was
very interesting you said am i being too
stubborn to let anyone in
due to my defense mechanisms or do i
have a right to feel
and a force the way that i feel i think
that's a
i think that's a very weird way to
question i don't think we're talking
about enforcing
negative habits right i don't think you
should enforce a negative habit but you
should understand why you do have a
defense mechanism
for letting people close to you yeah
there's once you start to understand
that and
it seems like in your case therapy would
be a very good situation
if you don't have positive people in
your life right now that you could speak
to and give you
uh uh lend you an ear to listen to all
these problems uh therapy might be the
route for you
uh i i it's not for everybody it doesn't
work for everybody but it seems like for
me it might
in your case it sounds like therapy
would work yeah just because um
i don't want you to feel like having
your your walls up 24 7 to everybody is
a good habit to have
i think it's smart i think it's smart to
keep your [ __ ] close to your chest
but when you kind of stop when you kind
of let let your past define you
and your future relationships this is
where
uh like kind of problems will begin to
sprawl just because like you don't know
who to trust anymore
you're not really practicing um
developing relationships now now every
time that you're with somebody you have
a red flag up
and you're expecting people to fail
around you which i have seen
consistently
all the time yeah a lot of people that's
been through trauma like i i
what i call it is like um i would kill
people
before they can kill me in my head right
so like if you destroy them in your head
or you destroy their character in your
head
um then what ends up happening is like
you you have this sense of certainty and
you don't feel like they're gonna
backstab
you anymore because you already it's
it's it's really [ __ ] up because
it's almost like before they can hurt us
we're going to make sure that we hurt
them or we're going to make sure that we
don't trust them
so that we never get hurt but what what
ends up happening is sometimes we just
literally go out and hurt people when
they didn't deserve it it's a
self-fulfilling prophecy sometimes
because you'll you'll meet somebody and
because
of a lot of your past trauma you kind of
define
these new relationships the same way you
define your past terrible relationships
and so when these people do mess up they
do kind of [ __ ] up or they have these uh
these behaviors that you that you have
for you of someone yeah it reminds me of
someone in your past and then you say
the word
i knew you were gonna do this in the
first place yeah so you kind of already
set people up to fail
before they're even given a chance to be
an important part of your life
so you you do have to be a little
careful about that in my personal
opinion this is obviously isn't a
professional opinion
but i have seen personal friends who do
this where they
look at somebody they go i knew you were
going to do this
yeah and it's because they've been
through so much pain and trauma
and like problems from the closest
people in their lives like their own
parents right
so they you know the way we see the
world
it usually is because of when we're
young like
it's normalized like whatever our
parents show us they're the gateway
to the reality but once you get to the
point where you
see so many different families the way
they do
things what's normal to other people you
realize that reality is different for
everybody yeah and so you you have to
question
at some point the way that i see the
world is that even real
because that's just been my life and i'm
kind of comfortable in it
but if i really want to get out of here
i got to try different things
and trying different things means having
courage
uh to maybe love to giving somebody a
chance
and maybe that chance could be hurtful
who knows but if you don't push the
boundaries
and and constantly try to be courageous
you're not going to end up finding that
peace that you want that's a guarantee
because if you stay the way that you are
right now and you continuously think the
way that you've been thinking
and you let your past define you then
the destiny
is literally gonna be where you at right
now
till you die yeah and when you when you
asked in the beginning
like i said i've never been in a gang
but i've known quite a few people who
have been and i kind of grew up around a
lot of people who didn't like gang
violence type of [ __ ]
and you're talking about you know how
how would you leave a gang
i i mean to be honest with you i'm gonna
reference uh one of my friends who left
his gang and what he was kind of saying
to me was that
um he left the gang after he went to
prison so they they used to
jack a lot of cars and back in the day
when you jacked the car
your your sentence was pretty [ __ ]
long and now the prison system is so
impacted
you get a [ __ ] slap on the wrist you
might be in there for a few months he
was in there for six [ __ ] years
so six years and he came out left the
gang or whatever right and kind of what
he said to me was
uh and he was opening up during um
it's basically this church activity
where you kind of tell your personal
story and your life story
and what he said that he kind of defined
himself and what the group was always
telling him he was
right he didn't really have a definition
of who he was he didn't like his family
life and so what he gained
was a perspective and love and family
from these group of people but at the
same time
he said that it wasn't really a lot of
love because
if he didn't do what they told him to do
they would ostracize him as well
so he was skinning the same conditional
love that he got from his parents just
in a different group
setting but what he kind of got uh drunk
off of was the power that you get when
you're a part of a gang right
that safety that you get but what he
started to realize was that
his individuality couldn't be expressed
uh he had to follow along with what
everybody else said he would have to do
a lot of [ __ ] that other people had to
do and for him when he went to prison
and you know obviously when uh as an
asian american
or actually any type of race from what
i've heard like you have to
align yourself with the ethnicity inside
the jail right yeah
so he he faked the funk for those five
or six years that he was in jail and
when he came back out
he's like [ __ ] this i'm done with this
stuff because he lost his individuality
he he thought that he was gaining
something from this group that that was
his everything and
really they took a lot of [ __ ] from him
they took his individuality they took
away his free thought
and all for what just so he could look
like a tough guy so the hard part about
this and i think for him when he
left the gang life and a lot of these
people were waiting for him to come out
of prison
that he had to deal with this moment in
his life where he had to be alone
yeah he said that that was the hardest
part for him was that
all of his friends were a part of that
gang and when he didn't want to do it
anymore
yeah uh and he left by the way he got
jumped out
when he came out of prison they [ __ ]
his ass up from what he told us
he had to be alone by himself with no
community
and that was the hardest part but for
him kind of like the light at the end of
the tunnel was that
he knew that he was going to surround
himself around the right people
and when he came to that church he
surround himself around the right people
damn that's
way more well thought out and planned
than me
because the way i left was i just didn't
see a future in it because uh we went
through a gang war and a couple of guys
got killed
and um the older guys we gave him money
to buy his guns so we can retaliate
so i wanted to continue being a gangster
and then they
used our money for crack what the like
yeah and i said what kind of a [ __ ]
gang is this like
so in my situation i probably would have
stayed if they supplied me with guns
and i'm like but i saw what a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] everything was and i'm
like
really like you guys are that
irresponsible and i'm like
i can't be a part of this [ __ ] man
so i didn't want to leave by myself so i
manipulated half of the crew
um well not manipulated like i got in
their years and i
and i found one ally and i found another
ally and we we
basically orchestrated a leave
they can't they couldn't [ __ ] jump us
up or or [ __ ] us all out
or beat us up or whatever like if
majority of the youngsters leave what
are they gonna do nothing
yeah just feel bad about the situation
the gang is defunct we killed it
and a lot of them have uh resentment
toward some of the members or whatever
and i'm just kind of like well
yeah i saw the stupidity i didn't quite
leave completely because i was like i
said like if they supplied me with guns
i would have been
going because i wanted to i wanted that
life i wanted more money and and i think
i boiled it down to why am i in this why
do i need a name
like why do i need a club name and do
all this [ __ ] like
i have my friends like that left the
group will still
run drugs will still do other things
right so i'm like why don't we just
do that and so we continued doing that
and then we realized
you know some people kept going to jail
and then we're like well
it doesn't really make sense um it's
hard
you know and i think for a lot of people
who are kind of on the the judgmental
side of this they go
gangs are dumb why would anybody join
gangs and you're kind of getting a
glimpse of why people do join games
right now you're looking at this girl's
personal life
right and you're looking at other people
who had you know broken homes
they find comfort in other people people
do it all the time they're my buddies
that was exactly that
yeah yeah my mom was always out working
you know she was always depressed i
hated being
home around her and we would just be at
this one guy's house it was like a
clubhouse we just
hung out there like did whatever we
wanted party his parents were never home
we slept there for like weeks it was
like camping with your buddies
yeah and yeah so i think
like for us it was like well we could do
all the work without any of the violence
or whatever so let's just keep doing it
but eventually i think it was a slow
change
but for me i started to realize that the
world
isn't this way yeah and
some people were encouraging me to go to
college and all that and that just
changed my
my whole entire world but it wasn't
something that i plan to do
you know it's kind of like organically
went that way and if i can look back
i don't think anything could have come
convinced me to not sell drugs
yeah i think the only thing that
probably could have convinced me is
going like
hey if you do this legitimately
you're not gonna go to jail you can do
this like you can build a business
you don't have to be some genius to do
it you can do it like if someone just
told me that
i would have been like really how i just
didn't have a mentor
there's just a lot of like temporary
satisfaction that a lot of people feel
you know
for me too like so but so joe's like a
few years older than me and during
his time i think that's there was like
this certain peak of when
um where it where where a lot of this
gang violence and glorified gang
violence was happening and
towards my ears started to die out a
little bit yeah so it wasn't as cool
that's when your generation's more like
people are becoming emo
yeah and then like they're getting into
that kind of music exactly
so you know during my time when
you know a lot of a lot of the homies
were still in gangs but it wasn't as
deep as it was for yours because
there was a lot of race riots there was
a lot of race violence yeah like asians
versus black people mexican you know all
this other stuff even though sacramento
was inclusive
the gangs weren't you know so they they
were they were mad violent towards each
other
like schools were having lockdowns
because of shootouts and all this other
stuff
and then for me during that time like i
still had friends that grew up in that
type of lifestyle just because their
older brothers were abundant does
you know and for a lot of people for
reference there's a lot of asian dudes
that were older than us that were in
gangs because they were bullied because
when they came to this country they
couldn't speak the language
people were [ __ ] them up they were
robbing them and so they said
i'm from a war-torn country if you want
to see some [ __ ] up [ __ ] i'll show you
some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
and so you'll this is how their gang
started to develop so that kind of stuff
kind of trickled down
into the generations after and so for me
when it came
when it came to me we had a we did a
couple of bad [ __ ] here and there but i
never really quote unquote joined a gang
number one i didn't i didn't grow up in
a broken family so i felt my family
elsewhere
right i was still technically
quote-unquote a church boy and
three i just i didn't have a i was kind
of a [ __ ] i didn't i wasn't about that
[ __ ] life
you know i wasn't about that [ __ ]
life at all like i in
in terms of me getting the fist fights
was just because i got bullied a lot
yeah that was about it but in terms of
me going out trying to kill somebody
yeah that wasn't something i could not
absolutely do
it's not something that i grew up with
um it wasn't something that i really
found entertainment in
um i told the story once before where i
got it i had a gun
from a homie of mine and even having
that gun felt [ __ ] weird
but i took it because i felt pressured
you know it's like yo you're gonna need
this [ __ ] blah blah blah
i'm like thanks you know i wanted this
[ __ ] gun it's just
this odd object the only time i ever
thought i was gonna use this
was when my house got shot up because of
a prior mistake that other people made
that i was involved in
and i remember that moment and my
brother remembers this too because
i think i talked about this before but
just for people who haven't heard the
story
it was the night before i was going to
go to riverside my house was supposed to
get shot up the neighbor's house got
shot up
because they hit hit up the wrong house
yeah they were going to shoot me up
because i was associated with other
people that's how terrible that [ __ ] is
i'm not a gang member but just because
i'm friends with them they don't give a
[ __ ]
that's why you gotta get out exactly
get out of there for me in that moment
though it wasn't a gang
i chose not to be friends with those
people anymore
because what could have happened my
family could have got shot my mom and
dad could have died my brother could
have died
and this was the night before i was
going to uc riverside and so
by the grace of god none of us got
killed but i remember i went inside
i grabbed my grabbed that gun and i was
shaking because i've never used a gun
before
i just had that gun and then i kind of
stuffed it in my pants i walked outside
and dude i remember this it was a
[ __ ] mustang that came up with
underglows rolls up on the [ __ ] lawn
the guy's about to pull his gun out on
me and i [ __ ] you [ __ ] not
ask my brother ask my mom and dad right
when that happened
the [ __ ] helicopter light came down
boom guy freaked out and he jetted
so that moment because of a poor mistake
that i made to hang around people that i
shouldn't
have been around i could have died for
no [ __ ] reason
just because i was associated with the
wrong people and when when i cut those
people out in my life and it was it was
a slow process it wasn't completely
just because in my mind because i used
to get bullied a lot i thought that i
always needed those people in my life
like just in case something happens
which when i was in riverside i told the
story too i did call them up once
because of a [ __ ] house party fight
that happened
and i was like what the [ __ ] am i doing
it was this weird sense of protection
that i always felt that i needed
i wasn't a part of the game but because
we grew up together they were always
very protective of me yeah so i got kind
of fortunate in that sense in that type
of way
but is it worth me almost getting shot
for what yeah because i hung out with
them at a [ __ ] bowling alley
and then my face was there and then
somehow somebody found out where i lived
and they tried to [ __ ] kill me and my
family and i got lucky that they shot up
another house and i was even more
fortunate that those people didn't get
hurt
so you know yeah that's literally that
life man
i remember i was at a scary it's not
worth it i was at a talk recently a
little pre
corona earlier this year um i was
i was talking in austin and one of the
kids were like
hey man so like i i was able to leave
the gang and he's like
um or associated he goes and my friend's
still like
doing that and i'm trying to get him out
and he goes but he won't listen to me
what should i do and i said
leave him and all the students there
were like oh that's [ __ ] up joe like i
heard it
if they were just like no like and i was
like wait you guys don't understand
like i'm saying that so this guy
is saving his life he say he has to save
his own life and i was like you guys
don't understand how the gang
works he goes they don't care if you
left a gang
or you're a part of the group or not
like as long as they see
you associating you're you're there like
imagine if he's still hanging out with
this buddy his buddy didn't leave the
gang
the rivals see him and they shoot him do
you think the rival's gonna only shoot
one guy they're gonna shoot all the guys
that are hanging out and then
the students didn't get it like they
were just like oh [ __ ] really
like uh i couldn't get the to me i was
like
bro yeah you gotta leave you gotta leave
the situation and everyone's like no
oh like i was like why are you saying no
you know why it's because also you know
it's a generation thing if they haven't
been around somebody being killed
they don't understand when somebody
sprays they're not looking for specific
people
they're shooting up a whole [ __ ]
house when my neighbor's house got shot
up
they just sprayed yeah that's all that
it was yeah
and then when i came out this dude
rolled up just because i was coming out
mad aggressive right you know
if i stayed in the house probably
nothing would have happened yeah but
then i was so scared and freaked out
why first of all i didn't know that they
were shooting up the the neighbor's
house i thought they were shooting at my
house
but there was a kid in sacramento it was
this asian kid
and a buddy of mine does a lot of
after-school programming in sacramento
and
some of the hood spots this kid's sweet
as ever right and there was a news
article
put out about him he was getting his
life together
his family heavily involved in gangs he
was out in front of the house
on the porch at their like barbecue a
party rival gang came up sprayed the
whole house he was the only one that
died
damn what the [ __ ] so this is not a
reality for a lot of people
so when they hear that they go oh how
can you leave them it's like because if
you're associated with them
nobody gives a [ __ ] that you're
associated yeah you just can't even
be a part of it you got to leave and
then and that's my whole thing is that
you got to get the [ __ ] out of there i
mean
for me too like even after i stopped
being a part of this
like i was a part of the life for a
couple years afterwards meaning like i
was
doing criminal activities and then i
would still associate with some of the
guys and they're just like yo come kick
it let's just have dinner right and then
the last draw for me was
several years down the line i was in my
mid-20s i was already in college
and then they're like yeah let's go
let's go to the club and i'm like okay
we're just gonna party
nothing wrong with that we go to the
club one of their friends
stabs somebody so we have to [ __ ] get
the hell out of there so we get out
right
but then on top of that we go and we go
eat
afterwards at a cafe and then the girls
that are in
the group they don't like this other set
of girls and in the middle of the
restaurant they [ __ ] start
fighting and guys are trying to stab
each other with utensils and [ __ ] and
i'm just like this is [ __ ] ridiculous
right
so i was just like man let's just go in
our car
to another place fine and then another
right when we're about to leave another
group of guys within the group was like
hey can we come eat with you we want to
get out here too
and then my my friend was like yeah
let's just go to another cafe so we go
when we get there we park we're walking
outside trying to walk into the next
cafe
and a car drives by and [ __ ] starts
shooting at us
[ __ ] that this is like gta in real life
right and then that is
the last part when i was like man i
can't even get a [ __ ] meal
without like and then i was like
what am i doing man like i'm a college
kid now like i'm i'm different like i'm
doing things
that's [ __ ] nuts this is stupid right
[ __ ] nuts so
that's why um and then within that group
too i'm friends with them but i told
them like man i don't want to [ __ ]
hang out with you guys like
we'll chat and and we're friends like
let's go with church barbecue
yeah yeah and because they're still
about that life and so
yeah like just the other day i had to
talk my buddy out from
killing somebody and um man it's
ridiculous we're 36 years old and it's
like
what the [ __ ] right like we're we went
different ways
and i still care about them a lot like
we've been friends for over
15 years you know or more and
and the way that they think
it's like and they make really good
money now
doing legitimate business and it's like
you're a businessman you're making
you know 50 70 000 a month
people would dream of this kind of cash
what the [ __ ] are you doing it's crazy
how those habits are so hard to kill for
some of these guys man yeah
and it's kind of that life scares me so
much and i've even been fortunate enough
where
you know k-town has still a lot of
[ __ ] violence here right
i remember so there's this bar in cape
town that i used to go to a lot
but when i walked in i ki i [ __ ] you not
so i walk in
and you know there's a bunch of dudes
just standing outside right well kind of
like like
you know like the the younger people in
the crew right they're kind of they kind
of just got into the gang yeah and
they're the more volatile scary ones so
if you guys don't know
if you see the young people in the group
they will do anything
they can to stay in there and to prove
their worth yeah they're the ones that
pop off
so i'm about to walk into this bar right
it's a bar that i used to frequent a lot
dude comes up to me and he puts his
hands on my chest he goes don't come in
i'm like why he goes because i watch
your youtube videos
you go i like you a lot i'm saying it's
not a good time i'm like
oh okay so i walk away i thought that
night somebody got stabbed
oh you know what i'm saying i am there's
some [ __ ] that happens in this world
and it's so weird when people hear when
people talk i feel like
the younger version of myself even
though i wasn't in a gang or gang
affiliated because i was around this
group of people
if i was in that type of like scuffle or
some [ __ ] it would make me feel like
i was dope if i was a part of it you
know but as an adult
when i see that i'm like i'm getting the
[ __ ] out of here this is frightening
that was
you i mean you tell these stories of
being in a fight back in the day and
it's like it's like you're a warrior
you're like
you you know it's like a glory you just
relive in your [ __ ] past right yeah
but now when i'm looking back i'm like
[ __ ]
dude that's some [ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah
it's it's it's a
completely different way of looking at
it you know
yeah and when i when i see like young
people like that and
you know i kind of look at them and i'm
like i wonder where
this person is going to be later on in
life um
and you and you never really know
because some people um like edric
when we were at this uh same bar he
we walked into the front of the same bar
and i kind of saw a group of people i
already knew what that means i'm like i
kind of want to go into this especially
after that last time
yeah where the dude kind of thank god he
knew who i was he was like nah don't
come here today right and so i walked
away
but that guy that he met up was as large
as [ __ ] asian dude yoked this [ __ ]
bald head and he just run a lot of young
cats and i'm like
that's head honcho these are all the
[ __ ] young gunners right
and immediately when he comes up this
guy's just like staring at me
yeah and i feel so uncomfortable i'm
like this guy's gonna [ __ ] kill him i
love your video
that'd be funny if he was like that but
you know lo and behold afterwards
andrew's like nah you're cool you could
come in i'm like nah i'm good dude i'm
just gonna walk away and then he kind of
told me about the dude's backstory the
guy's a [ __ ] psychopath
you know and he's still doing that [ __ ]
he's still doing that [ __ ] and it's like
i i don't know about that man that just
scares me yeah
weird well i hope that helped you out
um i mean your life life story is pretty
[ __ ] crazy and it's interesting like
hearing how young you are
and the stuff that you went through
because it's very reminiscent of of our
past
you know and people that we've been
around still happens i mean if you think
about it right like
her parents are probably a little older
than me
yeah just a little bit that's right huh
because they had her super young yep
that's insane it's funny too cause like
so
my friend's girlfriend she was like you
know what joe i'm like what
you are closer to my parents age than
you are to me
because her parents had her young two
and they used to oh really with the gang
and all that stuff
that's just crazy yeah but they changed
and they they got out of all that
that's [ __ ] nuts well i i hope that
helped you out
um you know kind of relating it to our
lives and stuff but
my dear lady uh we'll call you priscilla
i know that you didn't tell us
uh to not take your name out but i think
i'm just gonna
say people's names in general because
why um yeah very personal story thank
you for sharing uh i hope you guys got
to listen to a lot of insight
there's honestly so much more stories
that we can tell yeah we could go on for
days about this stuff
but uh joe where can they find you you
can see me
on my instagram at joejitsukawa
and then uh check out the the 90 days to
freedom yes you guys will see that link
in uh in the description box below
and we'll see you all next time thank
you very much
peace